okay hello everybody thanks for coming
and I know this is a Python conference
but I'm not going to talk about Python
today I'm going to talk about Julia I
don't know as a faster way as you I
would like to know how many of you have
heard about Julia so everybody and how
many of you have like at least throw one
line of code into a cool because
generally people know about Julia but
they never like try it so that's pretty
cool so okay I'm not going to talk about
Julia in general I'm going to talk in
particular about a library that I'm
developing in Julia so multi-dimensional
signal processing library which is
called she lab to jail and he has
implemented two typical signal
transformations that are called the
wavelet transform and the Sheela
transform but none on like you don't
need to be an expert of the wavelet or
Shila transform I'm going to explain it
and motivate the creation of them and
why it's important to have to have them
implemented in a fast and
high-performance language like us so
first of all we want to know where is
our definition of signal and this is a
quite informal definition but the still
mathematical definition of the signal
and the signal is a function or
something that can be represented as a
function that contains information about
the behavior attributes of some
phenomena and here the key word is it
contains information so things that
contains none information like white
noise is not a signal it can be digital
it is discrete or analog that is
continuous for example this is a digital
signal and discrete sample samples of
the signal we will form at the script or
digital signal and here is white noise
is not a signal so as we said signal
carries information and relevant
information in structured data it sparse
the problem is not that it is part of
the premise we need to know what is the
good representation system to have a
sparse representative of our signal and
this representation system will be
useful not just to compress the signal
to be able to transmit it or to store it
optimally but also to get the features
of the signal because if you get the
relevant information of the signal then
you will get to know that important
features that form the signal and this
is because like relevant information
will have a high correlation of its
element for example in this case so our
goal in signal processing is find the
right dictionary or representation
system to represent optimally our data
in this case you have a vector of blue
so a good representation system with the
different shades of colors and therefore
the coefficients on this representation
system of blue it will be the different
shades of the blue so it will be mostly
zero and that is what we call a sparse
representation so along the time alone
history has been different attempts to
represent the most general signals
sparsely the first one the first known
one is the Fourier transform it was
proposed by just a Fourier French
mathematician in 1822 and he saw that
some certain functions can be optimally
represented as assume of cosine and
science functions and the B variable
that you get with this with this
transformation will be considered as the
frequency so basically you get all the
frequencies in your function in your
function for example here you have a
function that is just like a cosine and
of course or sum of cosine and sine of
course it's representation will be quite
the sparse because you will just have
like for example in this case two
frequencies of course not
in every case you will be able to
represent optimally signal with cosines
and sines for example Cygnet I have like
more complex frequencies in Julia do you
have FFP a fast Fourier transform
implementation which is quite fast and
it's based in the in the classic FFT
that is also implemented in Python and
in MATLAB and in this case for example
I'm creating a function that is just
sine of two pi T plus two cosine of six
pi T Square of course this is a function
has no much not many different
frequencies and therefore when you
calculate the fast Fourier transform
which is in this case just applying the
function f of T you will be able to see
that mostly all the elements are zero
just three frequencies here are relevant
so therefore you can compress the signal
just eliminating the other terms and of
course you can you can recover the
signal just applying the inverse
transform which in this case is is
performed by the function at e FFT and
then you get the same signal right now a
fully transform has a lot of problems as
I said like functions that have a lot of
frequencies will not be optimally
represented by fully transform and it
also has no time information so when you
apply the Fourier transform if you see
here you take the integral over over all
the time or all over all the space
therefore you will know the frequencies
but you will never know when the
frequencies happen or where the
frequencies happen and this this
property you like to have in some
applications like sound processing when
you will like to know like when this
sound happen of course this like the
easiest way to tackle this problem is
instead of integrating over all the time
or over over all the space to take a
small small windows functions and you
take the Fourier transform in these
windows functions and then you move the
windows functions along the time or
along the space and so you will have
local information about the frequencies
as well this is called a short time
Fourier transform and it was it was
presented by Gabor's a
Denny's gavel which actually was in
battling in what before was the
Technical University of Berlin and he
was presented in 1946 and the forum is
like that so it's like the fully
transform if you see but now you have
this function G which is a Windows
function that you can move a long time
it's can be seen as these so you have
two small small windows functions and
you get the Fourier transform in locally
and then you move the windows function
but discuss problems which are more
technical one of them is like the
systems generated but this transform are
called this representation system is
called AG our system and our system have
something that Fourier transform has a
problem that is the uncertainty
principle there is the same like in
quantum mechanics like you will not be
able to localize perfectly time and
frequency at the same time which will
carry some problems in applications of
course and also we have the problem that
we don't change the size of the windows
function the size of the windows
function is the same all the time
therefore you will not be able to get
features are very localized like
singularities for example and now as we
as we done before that we didn't have
any time information there were
therefore we take a windows now we don't
have different sizes information now
like the easiest way to tackle this
problem is just change the size and this
is made by a transformation called the
scaling and just applying scaling or
changing sizes of the windows function
in the short time fourier transform is
what is called a wavelet transform it's
actually well known because it was
implemented by the JPEG codec and the
wavelet transform is just the same as a
short time Fourier transform but now you
divide by parameter a which will
modulate the size of the windows
function yeah so you can represent this
as a convolution of your function with
some other function which is your
wavelet and convolution and scaling
transformations are operations that are
well known in signal processing and in
discrete-time are performed by something
called filtering and other thing that is
called this table sampling this is kind
of like the compression in between the
short time Fourier transform and the
wavelet transform the short time for in
turn so you see the windows function
doesn't change and the in the web the
web will transform the windows function
change therefore you will be able to get
very localized information like
singularities okay so in this library
which is called she lab in India which
is already it's already registered as a
package in India so you can just in if
you have already Yuliya in your in your
computer you just need to to do this
this line of code package that app shoe
lab and it will be installed directly in
your computer so we can call the the
library just using chillip and as I say
the wavelet transform is performed by
having a windows function moving it and
then also SK learning to change the the
size of the windows function in one
dimension is really easy because you
just have you have one direction where
you will scale and you will move in two
dimensions is a little bit harder
because now you have two directions so
in this case you will scale in one
direction you will scale them in the
other direction therefore as you are
scaling with the same amount of scales
then you do we have an isotropic scaling
you you will not have like different
sizes in different directions which in
some cases is really important but in
other cases is actually a problem so in
this case I need to generate first of
all a filter which will be the discrete
representation of our wavelet function
and then I will I will load a weight
so I will load an image which is this
image scroll bar bar is actually a well
not image in signal processing an image
processing and this image of course is
in this case as you are in grayscale
it is just a matrix of numbers which
represent the different the different
intensities in each in each point in
each pixel so therefore I can perform
the wavelet transform which is just
subsampling and filtering which
represents scaling and convolution with
a function and in this case as we just
have two directions of scaling we would
just have information that is horizontal
that is vertical and there is diagonal
therefore you will catch edges or
features in your signal that are in
these different these three different
directions in this case as you can see
this looks like our image our original
image but now you just get their
horizontal information in different
scales of course whether more scales you
take you will have a better
representation of your signal because
you will have more different sizes that
you will represent in this case is the
vertical one in this case is diagonal
one and you can get the signal you can
recover the signal by just doing the
inverse the inverse operations which is
up sampling and filtering with inverse
filter and then you can get the signal
of course if you take as I said if you
take just five for example five scales
five different sizes the recovery of the
signal is not so good was quite quite
pixel but then you get more skills you
get better better recovering here I'm
killing some skills therefore the signal
is compressed but of course you will
have to duel you would like to have a
compressing memories that also has a
good quality and this is the trade-off
that
it's like a lot of problems in signal
processing airbase you can also say ok
now we have different coefficients that
represent different scales and different
I mean different sizes and different
positions our signal on our signal and
some of these coefficients will be
important and some of them will be not
important for example if you happen
image if I have mostly edges are aligned
with the horizontal vertex then you will
you will just need the the coefficients
there are correspondent to the
horizontal element and here you can say
ok then I can I can do a trance called
operation which says I get a trace hole
and then I kill all the coefficients
that are below this trace call which is
killing coefficients are not so
important and you will have also you can
do a recovery with coefficients that are
important and in this case I'm taking a
good fresco and therefore the recovery
is quite good which gives you a signal
to noise radio 25 which is actually
pretty good and therefore that's why the
wavelet transform is a good transform to
make compression codecs and that's why
they use it in the JPEG codec standard
now as I say you are doing a scaling in
both directions with the same amount and
this is a problem because you have it so
traffic elements you will not be able to
enclose things that are not isotropic
things are different different
directions and where the transform has
also the problem that you don't change
the orientation of the elements
therefore you don't have Direction
sensibility and actually most of the
natural images that exists in the world
have features that have a certain
direction so you do like to have
Direction sensibility to be able to
capture them and as we need to have a
abstract framework to represent natural
images that we like to represent
ultimately and this abstract framework
is called the cartoon-like functions and
the control egg function basically
argues functions are piecewise smooth
that have also the boundaries where
they're smooth are also smooth this can
be seen as this just like yeah like
things that can be represented by
piecewise smooth like almost every every
image that you can see can be
represented as this and Donoho think his
American mathematician which is pretty
good signal processing with well-known
he proved theorem about the
representation of cartoon-like functions
here you have something that is called
Sigma n that is the best n term
approximation error and can be
understood as how the coefficients in
your transformation decay so this the
lower is the best end time approximation
error the better is your representation
and in this case he said that if you
have a frame which is kind of a like
generalization of a orthonormal basis if
you have a frame of l2 then you will be
able to optimally represent your frame
until M to the minus 1 so the
coefficients associated to the system
will be will decay as fast as n to the
minus 1 no more no faster the wavelet
transform has a decay decay rate of n to
the minus 1/2 which is that is not
pretty good you can be able to you could
be able to ethically to be twice faster
than that and the problem is of course
then as you are doing in two dimensions
the same scaling in the two directions
then you just have like windows
functions are like squares or rectangles
and cubes that are not straight lines
are not well approximated by squares or
rectangles so you would like to change
elongate you
windows functions and also change the
orientation of your windows functions to
represent these cubes better and this is
what the Sheela transform does and the
Chiba transform issues like the natural
generalization of the wavelet transform
in the sense that you introduce a new a
scaling operator that change the sizes
of your elements in different in
different amount in the different
directions and achieving operator is
basically just like cutting your
elements which changes the orientation
of the elements here
what could say like why do you use
shearing instead of rotation which
rotation is like natural like the
intuitive way to change orientation of
things but orientation has a problem
when you want to implement it
numerically because when you're
implementing numerically you have like a
discrete grid and when you're rotating
the discrete grid you will not maintain
the grid of course and this is a problem
so the sheerly transform is just the
projection of your function with these
windows new windows functions that
depend in three parameters one parameter
of the scale of the size of your
elements one parameter of K that is the
shearing that is the orientation of your
elements and one parameter M that is
just moving like the translation of the
elements and when you are doing that
just like in disk in in this sense you
will get a tiling that is a covering of
the four-year domain of the frequency
domain that looks like this and this
telling is bad because if you have lines
in the frequency domain or features in
the frequency domain that are aligned to
the second to the Y Direction you will
need to have infinite number of hearings
to cover them so therefore this is a
problem you will have a really biased
transformation in that direction how you
solve this is you divide your fuller
domain in cones and in Anniston a lower
frequency domain which this is actually
taken from the wavelet transform because
in the Whaley transform what you do what
you say is
you like to cover the whole frequency
domain you will need to do infinite
number of scaling if in a number of
changes of size to be able to get until
the zero to be able to cover the whole
frequency domain and therefore if you
want to do a numerical implementation of
it you just have a finite number of
scales therefore you would like to then
just patch the low frequency domain and
then scale in the other in the other
places so you will have you will divide
your frequency domain in a low-pass
filter
domain in a low pass frequency domain
and in different cones and these
different cones you will perform the
sheerly transform there are two ways to
- there are two ways to pick this
function that is called the motor
function the Shibboleth function there
is one way to pick it a separable
function which is just the thread the
tensor product of two functions or as an
anti-parallel function will be the
supernal function times something that
gives you a direction that gives you
non-separable ax t it's very when you do
it in an odd separable way because the
tiling of the frequency domain does not
overlap so different elements will not
overlap in the frequency domain which
which give you a more optimal cover of
the frequency domain and it is proven
already that the best end and term
approximation error scales an end to a
minus 1 log n 3 half and log n when you
are really big can be taught as a
constant therefore you are kind of
getting the optimal best end term
approximation error therefore you are
getting a very good representation
system for 2d signals for for images and
therefore that's why it's really
important for different signal
processing tasks to be able to have this
implemented in your programming language
there is actually a Python
implementation of these really also now
there are different software's today
that implement the shilla transform
mostly there in matlab there is one that
was made in title mountain there is one
that was made in in university of
houston texas by the met
la Barthe under his window was made by
Gaeta Coutinho one killing rapid rising
off into Berlin and the group where
she's working she's one of the creators
dieter Coutinho is one of the creators
of the Shilla transform and I'm working
in her group and the group was the one
that made this she lab 3d which is the
most used by different different
universities and different institutes
the most youth implementation of the
Shiva transform but it is not live there
for MATLAB like doesn't make for me
doesn't make sense to do MATLAB things
for science because science should be
open source and MATLAB use will let the
people that have MATLAB or the license
of MATLAB to do it and it's also mad
level house is a basic was a basic type
it has the complex matrices and of
course it's nice to have complete matrix
as your basic type but when you're not
working with complex matrices then it's
a problem so doing for loops or other
kind of stuffs are quite slow there is a
Python implementation of this last
library which is called pylab was made
in University of göttingen I haven't
tried so I don't know how does it
perform in comparison with the Julia
transform with the Julia implementation
and they say shield lab implementation
that I did in Julia which is called
shield up the jail and why why is Julia
is a lion nice language to do signal
processing and in particular shielded
transform first of all sheila transform
using extensive use of fast fourier
transform which is well implemented in
Julia it has also Julie has also fast
vectorization options like the
vectorization of functions and loops
that are really fast because it
implements the JIT compilation the
just-in-time compilation has plenty of
image filtering import and rescaling
functions with two very nice libraries
yeah image dodge al and wavelet so GL
and have support of multi-threading and
painless GPU processing with array fire
da jail which I also use so very fast I
wish
you how I did the Shiva transport so
they shoulda transformed as I as I
explained to you I will use the same the
same image and I have a function okay
these are just parameters for the Sheila
transform I will use four scales instead
of eight scales that are using the
wavelet transform just to show you why
it's better and I have two functions
that generate the shielded elements
there is just taking your shield
function your model function and SK and
a scale and shear and move it and one is
non parallel and one is in GPU parallel
GPU parallel one is really fast and you
can see the different elements that look
like like windows there are align it in
different directions and I have
different sizes as I say this is the
windows that covers the low the low
frequency domain and now you can get the
coefficients associated with with your
with your image because of course the
elements are independent of the image
the elements are in general so you can
use these elements just take your image
and take the convolution of the image
with each of the elements and you will
get information of the image in each
direction and each size and then for
example in this case in the first
direction we have things that are
aligned in this direction like kind of
diagonal and then different directions
you see that the features are aligned in
different directions and you can do also
again assuming everything up you can get
the recovery of your image and is
actually just using four scales there is
the help that I used for the Chile
transform the affor the wavelet
transform you get a very good recovery
in this case you can see this is just
using four scales and here for the
wavelet transform when I use five scales
is really bad the recovery here I use
five scales is really really bad
so therefore that proves like shifflett
transform is actually better than when
we transform to represent images and now
wave I have some benchmarks of
comparison with the MATLAB library to to
show you why is why it's better so
MATLAB in this case is the blue line
here is the number of pixels in each
direction and Julia is the green line
and Julia using GPU is the black line
which looks like a constant it looks
like really easily here that MATLAB is
not it's not scalable for really big
images and the moss this is for the
generation of the system this is for the
Descamps position that is the
computation of the coefficients and this
is for the recovery which in all of them
looks like the beginning they perform
kind of the same and then when you get
until image that is bigger than 1024
pixels square like MATLAB just explodes
and Juliet steals quite scalable
actually the most impressive one is when
you are doing the reconstruction of 1024
x 1024 and you're using GPU parallel
computations you have the julia is 1 is
125 27 times better than matlab which is
actually quite impressive now other
things that you can do with this is
imagine that you have a signal or an
image that is noisy noise carries no
information therefore if you get the
shield transform the coefficients that
have the noise could be in the positions
that have less importance or coefficient
are smaller so if you kill them by
transcoding then you can denoise the
function so this is this is an image
that is noisy you can see it imagine
that Jesus have this image you get the
shielded coefficients and then you kill
the coefficients are less important
because I have less
Lessman absolute value okay and then you
denies the image and actually the des
noises is quite good if you compare with
the noisy one it's quite good also the
noise is part of the high-frequency
elements and high-frequency elements are
not so important in image in general
like image has no like big change of
sizes we change of yo size and then you
can do also another application which is
kind of the most impressive one is
called in painting and in painting what
what it does is like imagine that you
have an image and lossy image you have
an image of a house a lot of los parts
for example the image is really also
some of the parts fell down and these
parts can be represented as holes and
the holes are like big steps big fall
down in the image so these parts are
very very discontinuous and form a part
of the high-frequency elements in the
Fourier domain so you can use again the
Fourier the sheerly transform to cover
these parts kind of smooth out the image
and in this case you use something that
is called the iterative hard trace
holding which is optimization method
that is used a lot in income presenting
and then mind that you have this mask
random so it's an image that has random
parts that are lost and using the shilla
transform I can recover the image and
looks like this which is actually quite
impressive and then if you have for
example a squares you have an image that
have a squares error loss you can use
again the fully digital transform using
the iterative cartridge coding that
kills elements that have high frequency
you can get a recovered image like this
and well basically that's all the code
that I would like to show and this is
I'm using right now these two
to do a 3d recovery you can there is
something called light fuse recovery
light field theory which basically is
based than if you take different
pictures of a scene let's say different
pictures are not so separated from each
other then you can stack them in in this
kind of stack and then you can follow
for each let's say each horizontal line
you can follow the points and following
the points you get this kind of this
kind of linear structures so therefore
if you want to get the depth of each
point you just need to to measure the
slope of the lines here and you can
recover them the depth of each point and
therefore you can recover the 3d
information of the scene and of course
you need a lot of pictures to get a good
a good recovery of the depth but you can
just do a sparse sample of the pictures
and then you will get like something
like this instead of this you get
something like this and you would like
to in paint using different
transformation in paint this to recover
the original picture and using wavelets
looks like this if you use wavelets it's
really bad so you don't see any line
there so you cannot actually compute any
slope but if you use Siletz you can do
this and you can get a good recovery of
them and then using just small amount of
pictures you can recover the 3d
information of your scene and basically
that's all what I want to say thank you
so questions Christians think no
questions thanks for your presentation I
would like to ask questions about what's
your opinion on recent advancements in
declaring and convolutional neural
networks and whether this methods might
find representations of images that
would be easier to work with in specific
domains or would add generic image
decomposition using a well-known
functions like violets still will be
useful actually there is a paper about
this last year came out of piotrowski
i'm volce i can show you the paper and
in this paper because this deep
convolutional neural networks are were
originated by stefan molyneux in 2012 I
think so and he used wavelets to do that
but now they're like there is a paper
when guys from the eth sewage they
generalize these four different frames
and then they show that she LEDs are
part of this framework so therefore you
can use them for deep convolutional
neural networks and you will have good
good algorithms to do image recognition
thing basically so yeah if it can be
used shifflett transform for deep
convolutional neural networks and which
are really proven as gene was provided
the problem with these deep
convolutional neural networks are quite
generally do you have estimation of like
any much recognition problems you want
to have sometimes like translation
invariance so you would like to have to
be able to recognize a doc here or a doc
here no matter where but that the
estimate for that exists but there
doesn't exist estimate for the error of
the of the picture structure of related
to the big convolutional neural network
so therefore it's a good theory but you
don't know still how good are they
represent dating
things but yet then we are all hungry
probably hearing the noise coming
thanks a lot Hector thank you tick tock
[Applause]